[Music]
it's been just over 12 years
since the first twilight film exploded
across movie screens
despite the series's status as a box
office powerhouse
there are plenty of questionable
instances in the films that you might
have missed when you were a teenager
before he first appeared in the twilight
series as jacob black
bella's second love interest and
burgeoning werewolf
actor taylor lautner was best known for
his role
in the adventures of sharkboy and lava
girl
jacob wasn't a major character in the
first twilight film
but one detail stands out during his
scenes jacob's character
initially has long hair that reaches
past his shoulders
since lautner had short hair he had to
wear a pretty obvious wig for the role
team jacob teens might have been able to
turn a blind eye to the hair piece when
the first film was released but
it's pretty hard to miss as an adult not
only was the wig
super noticeable but lautner said that
the wig also caused
numerous technical issues on set
whenever stray hairs would fly into his
face
the crew would have to cut and start the
scene over
loutner also said there was mutual
hatred between him and his
wig and that he didn't miss it after the
series ended
luckily for him jacob's character
cropped his hair
after his transformation into a werewolf
in new moon
so he was able to part ways with the wig
for the rest of the series
according to lautner they even gave the
wig its own round of applause when its
roll
officially wrapped this is more of a fun
blank and you'll miss it sort of goof
but it becomes more obvious when you
re-watch the series as an
adult shortly after bella first meets
edward
at forks high school edward comes to her
rescue when a van careens toward her
in the school parking lot in the scene
bella is shocked at the impossibility of
edward's actions
from darting across the parking lot
instantly to stopping the force of the
van with his arm
it's one of the pair's first encounters
and also the first hint for bella that
edward is not your average teenager
but one detail that bothers viewers is a
small prop
in this scene just before the van spins
out of control
bella is putting things into her
backpack which is on the hood of her car
while edward prevents the van from
crushing bella it still hits the back of
her truck with considerable force
however when the film cuts to a wider
shot of the parking lot
as students rush to check on bella the
backpack is still
in the exact place it was before the
crash in a real-life scenario
her bag probably would have been sent
flying or would have at least fallen to
the ground
this was most likely a continuity error
or bella must have had a super strong
magnet in her backpack that held it in
place
a huge plot point in the twilight books
is that while bella wants to sleep with
edward he refuses to do so
until they get married repressed desire
also exists in
other forms in the twilight saga the
cullens naturally desire human blood
but cannot drink it while edward is
naturally drawn to bella because she's
the only person who can resist his
ability to read people's thoughts
edward's reasoning for not wanting to
sleep with bella has to do with his
superhuman vampire strength he believes
his desire is dangerous for bella
and that he could actually hurt her
edward's views
are not that surprising given some
context about his creator
the author of the twilight books
stephanie meyer is a devout mormon and
has said that her characters exhibit her
own beliefs and feelings about
premarital relations
even actor robert pattinson who
portrayed edward in the films
agreed that despite the steamy chemistry
between him and his co-star kristen
stewart
the movie's themes are very chaste
victoria was one of the longest-running
antagonists for bella and the cullens
throughout the series
in the first film her mate james is
killed by the cullens after he attempts
to kill bella
victoria managed to slip away amidst all
the chaos but she came back
looking for revenge in new moon during
the first two films
victoria was portrayed by rochelle
lefeve who reportedly prepared for the
role by pretending to be a cat
to match victoria's agility and demeanor
when the third film
eclipse was announced it was assumed
lefev would reprise her role as victoria
however the part was recast due to a
scheduling conflict between eclipse's
shooting schedule
and lefeve's commitment to shooting the
movie barney's version
the two film's schedules overlapped by
10 days
and summit the studio behind the
twilight films
was unable to change the shoot to
accommodate lefeve
the role eventually went to bryce dallas
howard who had previously turned it down
because it was
too small apart lefev was understandably
upset by the whole series of events
but summit was not willing to budge in
its decision to recast
the cover of the novel twilight is a
dramatically lit
image of two hands holding an apple
apples are traditionally a symbol of the
forbidden fruit
of knowledge and by extension desire
stephanie meyer
also confirmed that the apple on the
book's cover was a deliberate
biblical illusion themes of forbidden
fruit are consistent
throughout the twilight series and many
characters are drawn to
or desire things or people they cannot
have
if you watch closely actor robert
pattinson recreated
the now infamous twilight cover during a
scene in the first film
in the scene bella drops an apple on the
floor the apple then bounces off
edward's foot
and perfectly lands in his two palms the
whole thing happens
in just a few seconds but super
attentive fans were able to notice
and appreciate this easter egg since
vampires don't sleep
it only makes sense for edward cullen to
break into bella's house
and watch her sleep right do you do that
a lot
well just the past couple of months
edward encroaching on bella's privacy
rubbed some people the wrong way when
they first encountered the series as
teens
as adults we surely see his actions as
straight up creepy
and gross it would be weird if they were
already in a relationship but they
weren't even dating at this point
this is often the first bit of evidence
given when discussing how
unsettling edward's behavior is
throughout the series
robert pattinson's film depiction of
edward doesn't
exactly help his ominous image either as
he spent
most of the first twilight film staring
intently at his love interest
bella reads edward's mannerisms as
mysterious and they inspired millions of
teenage readers to fall in love with him
however it goes without saying that if
he were a real person
he'd be covered in giant red flags
he's also super possessive and
controlling of bella
consistently leaving her out of major
points of decision making in their
relationship
when bella is attacked by a fellow
member of edward's coven
he decides for her that their
relationship is too dangerous for her
rather than letting bella assess and
accept any risks for herself
edward puts the situation solely in his
control
which ultimately ends up sending her
into a depressive spiral
the anatomy of vampires in the twilight
films is pretty straightforward
their skin is impervious to sharp
objects they sparkle in direct
sunlight and they don't have blood
running through their veins
the only thing supposedly sharp enough
to break vampire skin
is vampire teeth which are used
throughout the twilight films
as weapons against enemy vampires and as
medical
instruments in breaking dawn so if
vampire skin cannot be broken
how does james have a tattoo in the
first twilight film
while fans may not have thought about it
too much when they became obsessed with
the films for the first time
it definitely doesn't make sense upon
closer inspection
if a scalpel couldn't break a vampire's
skin and breaking dawn
a tattoo needle definitely wouldn't be
able to place
ink in the skin the answer to this
mystery
is pretty straightforward the actor who
portrayed james
cam jagante has a tattoo and the film
didn't think it was necessary to cover
it up
james's tattoo wasn't exactly an
important element to his part of the
story so the creators of the film just
decided to let it slide
there's a lot going on in breaking dawn
part 2
but there definitely should have been
more screen time devoted to discussing
how
jacob bella's longtime friend and former
love interest
imprinted on her newborn baby you
nicknamed my daughter after the loch
ness monster
a lot of jacob fans simply wrote his
newfound protectiveness
and bond with renesme off as romantic
but there's a bit more to it than that
jacob's reveal that bella's baby
is his soulmate is a moment that's been
the subject of countless memes and
analysis
but a lot of people who watch the films
as teens have even more questions about
this plot twist
now as adults even if renesme grows up
faster than normal humans
wouldn't jacob be essentially grooming
her from childhood
what's the exact science behind
imprinting
why doesn't anyone else in the cullen
clan see any major
issues with this does renesmee have any
agency in this huge part of her life
at all in the films jacob's imprinting
on renesme
is kind of just explained away by
attributing it to
ambiguous werewolf idiosyncrasies that
might have been enough for teenagers
watching the film the first time
but definitely would earn more scrutiny
from those
same viewers today while stephanie meyer
was a household name by the time the
first twilight film
flooded movie screens worldwide not too
many people were familiar with meyer's
physical appearance
little did fans know that they could
easily find the creator of their
favorite series
right within the film adaptations
towards the end of twilight
there's a scene where bella and her
father are eating at the local forks
diner
the camera pans past a woman sitting at
the diner counter typing away at a
laptop
super attentive fans were able to
recognize this anonymous writer as
stephanie meyer but it was subtle enough
that more casual viewers might have
missed it
meyer also had a second cameo in
breaking dawn part 1
during bella and edward's wedding the
wedding scene had
huge hype leading up to the film's
release and when bella walks down the
aisle
you can see stephanie meyer standing
among all the other wedding guests
at the ceremony although stephanie meyer
said she had to be talked into
participating in the film shoots
her fans probably appreciated seeing
their favorite author on screen
according to the world of twilight
keeping the existence
a vampire's secret is crucial to any
vampire's survival
the valteri a large coven of vampires
who reside in
italy are recognized as the official
leaders of vampire society and enforce
the rules that are used to maintain
secrecy vampires in the twilight
universe are expected to follow the
coven's laws
and those who break the rules are
typically punished with
death such rules include avoiding direct
sunlight
since vampire skin would sparkle and
quickly draw the attention of any humans
nearby
however despite the cullens carefully
adapting their lifestyle to keep a
relatively low profile within forks
there are still plenty of times where a
reasonable person should have noticed
that something
was a little off for example while the
cullens explained to bella that they
settled in forks
because of how constantly rainy and
cloudy the climate is
there are still a few times that the
vampires were exposed to direct
sunlight in front of other humans when
bella sees the cullens for the first
time
they all sit down at a cafeteria table
together by
a window where a tiny bit of sun filters
in through the glass in this moment you
can see a bit of light
on alice's arm you think that for people
whose lives depend on avoiding the sun
they'd sit further away from windows
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about twilight
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one